i'm not a person who's good at surprises
i could cry right now i've lost my mind
my kids are pranksters she wants a big
bunch of bananas is it a chicken i can't
stand it here's why i don't trust matt
i'm a video game controller i was a
little bit shocked when i saw it
normally this is when i would have you
take a look at it no turning back now hi
i'm hannah i'm the world's okay mom and
i've let my kids decide a lot of things
from my hair color to our meal plan for
a week but i think it's time to up the
stakes what happens when i let my kids
design my newest tattoo will it be a
permanent mistake or will i love it
let's see wish me luck well guess what
boys you know how i have some tattoos
well i want to get another one and i
think for this one i'm going to let you
guys design it
would you want to do that yes yes
you would what okay what is go
where did you get that why did you hear
me
yeah
so here's the plan i'm going to let my
kids pick my next tattoo they're going
to work with a tattoo artist to make a
design and i'm going to get it tattooed
on my body without seeing it so the one
ground rule that i'm setting for this
tattoo is no poop no poop
poo i know my kids we all know my kids
you know my kids poop is everything poop
is life we're not doing any poop i don't
care if it's an emoji i don't care if
it's a realistic depiction of a big fat
we are not doing poop
that is the rule
no
poo
do you hear me
uh no i don't hear
[Music]
okay well good luck guys and they got
immediately to sketching
ooh can i just see
no oh come on
well i told them you know you're gonna
brainstorm with the tattoo artist you
really don't need to draw something and
they're like no no we want to come
prepared so we all got on a video chat i
got to meet erin and then i had to leave
the room matt stayed with the boys and
they got to talking hi i'm erin i'm
owner and tattoo artist at super sweet
coffee and tattoos in echo park as they
were brainstorming i heard a lot of
words thrown out like pizza
banana
back flip like
what is going on here so i was really
nervous that i was gonna end up with a
giant pizza slice i am outside so i
can't hear anything
but they've been in there for a while
and i'm starting to get a little bit
nervous
i hope they're in there because she's
talking them down from whatever bizarre
idea they have
or they could be figuring out a way to
make it work
so i'm very nervous
you know how it goes with my kids it's
like either zero or it's a hundred it's
like
oh my god
bug my kids are pranksters like jackson
really fashions himself a prankster so
he will totally do something like
tell the tattoo artist oh my mom loves
bananas she loves bananas she wants a
big bunch of bananas tattooed on her you
should do bananas with flames because
she also loves that
and then he'd think it was like the epic
prank when the boys presented their
initial ideas i thought
it was kind of all over the place but
they were trying to come up with
something really unique i could tell and
so we just sort of worked together and i
helped to guide them towards something
that i think hannah's really going to
like wait do you agree
why do you
okay he agrees
so after the video chat erin designed
the tattoo that she and the boys came up
with and she actually sent it to matt
matt did not make me feel good so it
looks bad
no but like you know i don't know 100
what you like you don't know what i
would like
when it comes to tattoos you got a lot
of different tattoos and they're kind of
all
different styles does it look good
for me
yeah it's it's you know it's simple it's
sweet
i don't know what else to say
you are making me so
nervous he made a couple comments of
like
i wouldn't get that and i'm like what so
i really started to spiral after talking
to him
i just need you to tell me
if it's a design i will be okay with it
i'm gonna be fine with it well
no turning back now
[Music]
just know that if i don't come home
it's because i don't like it
i'm here outside the tattoo shop i'm
very nervous because i thought i had a
sense of what the boys picked and i
think after talking to matt i realized
i'm very wrong he did not make me feel
very good about
what they chose i think
the design
looks good probably but he made it sound
like they picked something
kind of
lame so
[Music]
shall we go in
are we still doing this i guess we're
still doing this let's do it i step into
super sweet and it is where i want to
live i'll pack my bags and move in if
they don't mind it's gorgeous it's so
tasteful everything is bright and
beautiful and so thoughtful
and so i felt like i was in really good
hands when i walked in so i think that
this spot on the back of your arm just
above these crystals is going to be
really nice because i think these
designs kind of go together
and
that sounds promising
the first thing aaron did was shave my
arm which i was like are they not hairy
but they do it on any part of your skin
that has any even like micro hairs then
next she transferred the design onto my
skin
yeah this looks really cute and normally
this is when i would have you take a
look at it oh my god
so badly but
this is my choice at this point so i
think this is great and i hope you love
it
i laid down on the table and then
the painful part
sticking a needle in over and over and
over
it feels like
a really hot
knife scraping over my skin so this
tattoo experience
was very different from a lot that i've
had because i genuinely feel like and
again this ain't sponsored i paid for
this tattoo i stand behind my opinion of
this place i really think that they
created this shop to be accepting and
welcoming so here i am
feeling very good erin is super nice
and super
stylish and so i feel like
if she likes it i like it so i'm feeling
very good so while she was tattooing i
was trying to get a sense of what she
was doing or what shape it was or what
was even going on at all and i had no
idea this tattoo also feels like it is a
foot long i don't know what is wrong
with me
and my perception of my own body but
it's like
this is a one foot tattoo
it is it's literally eight foot
it's a tattoo of a foot and it's a foot
long yeah
and you're done
oh my gosh yay it looks so cute but
you're gonna have no idea the tattoo is
finished it really didn't hurt that
badly and it felt very efficient which
is awesome so i feel like the design
isn't something too crazy
the tough part is going to be
driving home without peeking but luckily
it's on the back of my arm so it'll be
hard for me to see
anyway in the car
with this i'm feeling very zen
i'm feeling really excited to show the
boys and i'm really excited to see it i
thought the final result was great i
think she's gonna love it it was nice
because it went with another tattoo that
she had i think the boys are gonna love
it i think it brings together a lot of
what they wanted and
a lot of what it seems that hannah might
like i think they're really gonna love
it i'm walking into the house
and i'm gonna show the boys and then i'm
going to see for myself and i'm really
excited i'm not nervous at all i'm just
excited
[Music]
are you guys ready to see
do you remember what you picked uh yeah
okay come here okay buddy
look honey one two three
oh frozen oh my god
that's so cool
oh don't touch it
[Music]
start
[Music]
so then the big moment finally arrived i
got to see my tattoo that everyone has
known about for weeks except me are you
gonna film my reactions okay okay ready
one
two
oh three gosh
oh this is amazing
[Music]
it says jackson wyatt
henry
i love it so much
oh my god now i'm gonna cry
[Music]
it was a moon
it was the moon
which is henry's favorite thing in the
world
[Music]
and it's surrounded by stars and in the
moon it has jackson wyatt and henry's
names
i love it so much this is so
perfect
thank you so much boys hugs
huggy
give me a big hug why thank you so much
sweetheart
when they were deciding on the tattoo i
really didn't think henry would be
included and what they did because they
are such good brothers they are such
good brothers to him
they made it about him too
and they did something that they knew he
would really love
and
that kind of thoughtfulness and empathy
is like
oh that's all you want to see in your
kids as a parent it has been a while
since i've cried in a video like welcome
back hannah
so that's all for now i'm hannah and
what did you think did you like the
tattoo should i let them do another one
let me know on instagram now if you'll
please excuse me i'm gonna go slather
some aquaphor on my new tattoo till next
time now make sure not to miss next
week's episode we are doing another food
around the world episode i'm cooking
seven new dishes from seven different
countries and this food is going to be
epic